Brad Pitt surprised serenade by Frank
Ocean JLo is proven age ain't nothing
but a number plus did Michael Phelps
just punked us and Ryan Gosling and
Harrison Ford
we got them comic-con leftovers for you
guys suing your own happy monday friends
this is the daily Denny and we are back
from comic-con and have even more
goodness from the convention for you in
a bit with a busy weekend with comic-con
in San Diego and the big music festival
here in LA
the FYF fest which drew a superstar
crowd I'm talking super duper fly missy
elliott slayed the stage during her
headlining set on a Friday and got the
support of Beyonce who took a break from
the twins to hang with her sister
Solange backstage during the see show
but check out who else was rocking out
to the rapper this is Super Bowl half
time collaborator prepared
[Music]
Oh Missy made Katie lose control and
Frank Ocean made me lose my mind the
blonde singer's fyf performance was
truly unforgettable and was made even
more memorable with an amazing cameo by
none other than rad frigging Pitt yeah
that's right Brad was there in the flesh
as he was starin aided by Frank's cover
[Music]
Oh Brad and Frank forever
apparently this bromance has been
brewing for a while now back in May Brad
opened up to Gigi style about life post
divorce and side to Frank's music as
inspiration quote I find this young man
so special
talk about getting to the raw truth he's
painfully honest he's very very special
and earlier this month Frank paid it
forward rocking this t-shirt with Brad's
face on it
like who knew I declared this the end of
the squad and the beginning of Ocean's
eleven thank you here all day alright
moving on to a duel I can't stop
obsessing over Jennifer Lopez and her
man Alex Rodriguez the couple was out
and about this weekend celebrating each
other's birthdays now if you can believe
it
JLo turned 48 years old today she put
her flawless body on a full display in
this very sheer black dress but look at
those ABS though she literally looks 28
I'd say that's not fair but that's until
I learned what her secret is apparently
she lives Queen which means no smoking
alcohol or caffeine and she works out a
lot in fact JLo spent her birthday
morning going to yoga with a rod and I
usually spend my birthday mourning over
pancakes at mimosa so I guess I'll never
meet you ABS alright looks just a
bromance thing going for a sec and take
you guys back to all the fun et had at
comic-con this weekend was full of wild
awesome moments in front of our cameras
but I'm not sure anything can top this
superstar pairing I'm talking Ryan
Gosling and Harrison Ford Ryan and
Harrison team up in the future world of
Blade Runner 2049 it's a sequel that has
been 35 years in the making
but watch what happens when Gosling
steps into Ford's interview with our
Kevin Frazier working together how I was
about what was it like it was horrible
yeah horrible I never attended by the
lamb right
you're right yes oh I thought it was a
virgin thought it was Ryan it used to be
yeah well not anymore
no Ryan told us Harrison is always like
that and for the man who is Indiana
Jones and Han Solo
Ryan says he's even cooler than those
characters but here's what we really
wanted to find out for Ryan you guys
remember that clip of Harry Styles I
showed you last week strapped to a hard
monitor when a photo ride Gus gets his
heart rate up well here's what ryan
gosling not a fad hey have you seen the
Harry Styles thing where you got a
reluctant ooh a heart monitor and they
showed him a picture of you and his
heart began to race I heard about that
again I'm worried about em - I think he
might have actually a heart condition
we're all laughing about it so fish you
got checked up you know any message you
want to send Harry what you should to
see a doctor quickly and you know sure
that he's all right well Ryan should be
checking up on Michael self after last
night's much-publicized
Shark Week stunt turned out to be a
great white ripoff millions watch
Discovery Shark Week kickoff special
where films was supposed to try and out
swim a shark but then something fishy
happened it was a simulated great white
that swam next to the olympian to
reflect the real one which beat michael
by two seconds anyway Twitter exploded
with some angry folk just check out some
of these tweets like quote it was just a
simulation I'm mad more like Shark Week
and hashtag Phelps hashtag jumped the
shark career over discovery tells et
today quote all the promotion interviews
and the program itself made clear that
the challenge wasn't a side-by-side race
come on guys did you really think one of
the most celebrated Olympians of all
time not to mention a father was going
to swim next to actual sharks you're
better than that
all right you guys I'm Pete we can kick
me in the butt so it's time to get out
of here but of course subscribe to ETS
YouTube channel so you don't miss an
episode of Daly Denny and stick with ET
online.com for all the latest in the
entertainment world I'm gonna shark my
way out of here